the weekend i'm sure he saw success in
his future but could he predict that
he'd be living in a 70 million dollar
mansion
[Music]
yeah the weekend's new digs are
breathtaking the 33 thousand square foot
bel air mansion has indoor and outdoor
pools a sport court movie theater music
studio gym and special turkish steam spa
[Music]
the 70 million deal is one of the most
expensive in la so far this year and get
this the home wasn't even on the market
the weekend's agent approached the
wealthy dutch couple who owned it
offering more than triple the price they
paid for it in 2015.
the weekend whose real name is abel
tesfay has an estimated net worth of
over a hundred million dollars and we
know he's willing to shell out cash for
what he wants earlier this year he
reportedly paid seven million dollars of
his own money for the super bowl
halftime show
this isn't the grammy winner's first
real estate transaction this year in
april he sold his 13 000 square foot
hidden hills home to madonna for 19
million
[Music]